hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte euch heute erst
mal alles gute fürs neue jahr wünschen
das ist jetzt mein erstes video im jahr
und ich hoffe dass ihr alle silvester
gut überstanden habt schön gefeiert habt
und natürlich auch dass ihr einfach
jetzt schön ins neue jahr startet ich
starte jetzt einfach mal mit einem
leckeren salat ich habe mir echt lange
überlegt was ich jetzt als erstes video
machen und habe gedacht komm nach der
ganzen weihnachtszeit nach der
silvesterfeier starten jetzt einfach mal
ganz leicht mit einem salat
ich möchte jetzt euch meine lieblings
salate vorstellen
und das hier heute ist mal eine meiner
absoluten lieblings salate das ist
nämlich ein nudelsalat der aber nicht so
typisch mit mayonnaise gemacht wird
sondern eher etwas mediterran mit
getrockneten tomaten mit feta käse und
mit etwas balsamico und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier 300 gramm nudeln das sind
jetzt bei mir falle also schmetterlinge
aber ihr könnt da auch ganz andere
nudeln nehmen
ich achte immer darauf dass ich kleine
nudeln habe dann brauche ich etwas
fetakäse da nehme ich jetzt ein rädchen
von diesem schafskäse also das ist ein
echter schafskäse und den nehme ich
besonders gerne weil der richtig lecker
wird sich schmeckt und sehr weich ist
ich brauche getrocknete tomaten die sind
jetzt in öl eingelegt und lecker gewürzt
etwas olivenöl etwas balsamico creme und
ein paar pinienkerne die ich gleich noch
anrösten werde
und hier habe ich bereits meinen rucola
fein gewaschen das waren jetzt 200 gramm
und in salatschleuder geschleudert damit
einfach wieder trocken ist dieser
mediterranen zutaten habe ich jetzt
wieder von bagdad gewählt weil ihr die
überall bekommt und die qualität stimmt
einfach auch also ich finde die zutaten
immer extrem lecker und qualitativ
hochwertig und deswegen benutze ich sie
auch so gerne
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal ein wasser
vorbereitet indem ich gleich meine
nudeln kochen werde koche ich jetzt
einfach nur noch mal kurz auf und gibt
da dann gleich die wohnung mit rein und
salze natürlich vorher das wasser ein
bisschen macht wirklich nur ein bisschen
nett sowie die sanierer immer so ganz
dem sport und sobald das wasser kocht
gebe ich da die nudeln rein und hol ihn
derzeit aber schon mal meinen feta-käse
raus ich lag hatte noch immer hier in
dieser blechdose in meinem kühlschrank
aber ich nehme jetzt ein komplettes
rädchen
hier gebe ich jetzt den nudeln rein und
gebe jetzt hier meine koch blumen drauf
dann kann das ganze nämlich schneller
wieder aufkochen und das wasser kocht
mir jetzt nicht über ich werde jetzt in
der zeit während die nudeln kochen
einfach schon mal meine zutaten klein
schneiden beim feta-käse mache ich das
jetzt so oder beim schafskäse viel sei
gesagt dass ich ja kein fehler sondern
echter schafskäse da mach ich jetzt so
dass ich den einfachen würfen schneide
und er ist sehr weich deswegen müsste da
einfach besser aufpassen
theoretisch könnte man auch zerbröseln
aber ich finde es schöner wenn ein
bisschen in würfel geschnitten ist meine
feta-käse gebe ich jetzt schon mal hier
in eine vorbereitete schlüssel rein
ihr müsst auch nicht komplett alles
nehmen aber ich nehme jetzt einfach ein
bisschen mehr weil sie auch 300 gramm
nudeln sind es gibt dann später echt
viel nudelsalat
jetzt nehme ich hier meine getrockneten
tomaten
die muss man ein bisschen abtropfen
lassen und da nehme ich jetzt einfach so
etwa zehn stück das könnte einfach nach
geschmack beliebig auswählen
deswegen gibt es da eigentlich keine
genauen mengenangaben und ihr könnt auch
zum beispiel einfach andere zutaten
nehmen auch frische paprika wird gut
dazu passen und die schneide ich jetzt
einfach schön klein
und die kommen jetzt hier auch mit rein
das ist auch ein salat den wir übrigens
super vorbereiten kann weil er einfach
auch ein bisschen durchziehen kann
jetzt nehme ich mir hier meinen rucola
ich nehme jetzt mal noch nicht alles ich
nehme nur die drei viertel etwa
und das geht da auch mit rein
und wenn die noten fertig sind können
dass er einfach ab gießen
und ich gebe dann meine nudeln auf ein
blech damit sie schneller abkühlen und
damit sie nicht zusammenkleben kommt da
jetzt einfach so einen spritzer olivenöl
noch dazu entstand vermisse ich die noch
kurz das war so ein typ der mir mal eine
freundin gegeben hat und die hat es von
einem griechischen restaurant leiter so
dann lassen wir es hier kurz abkühlen
und ich kann schon mal die pinienkerne
riss dafür nehme ich mir einfach eine
pfanne ohne öl und erhitzen sie auf
höchster stufe und gebt die pinienkerne
mit dazu
und jetzt warte ich einfach so lange bis
sie eben gebräunt sind
und wenn die müsste dann gerüstet sind
und ihnen könnte dann gebe ich hiermit
rhein sollte zugleich vorher ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen
aber ich musste jetzt aus der pfanne
nehmen sonst wären sie mir verbringen
und die zimmer auch klein schon fertig
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
basilikum und sucht das jetzt hier von
dem basilikum strauch ab und gibt es
auch mit rein da nehme ich jetzt einfach
gerne frischem basilikum weil da einfach
das aroma total lecker ist und ich es
auch schön finden wenn man dann auf die
blätter nachweisen kann
aber ihr könnt auch andere kräuter
nehmen und auch getrocknete kräuter
gehen gut dass schneide ich mir jetzt
hier einfach ganz grob rein und gebt da
jetzt meinen ottl mit dazu
und verrührt es jetzt mal kurz
und jetzt kommt dann noch die balsamico
creme rein und ich mag balsamico creme
ganz gerne weil die einfach nicht so
flüssig ist wie normale balsamico-essig
so leicht süßlich schmeckt unternehmen
da einfach so viel wie ihr möchtet könnt
aber auch ganz normalen balsamico
dazugeben und das werde ich noch mal
durchgeführt und ich brauche da in dem
salat ist auch gar kein salz weil ich ja
schon den täter oder den schafskäse drin
habe und die tomaten und die sind schon
deswegen würde ich da mit salzen sehr
aufpassen
wir haben uns jetzt übrigens vorgenommen
mehr salat zu essen also bei uns ist
salat immer so bis zehn jahren man mag
salat eigentlich nicht so gerne wenn ich
es macht dann muss es halt essen dann
ist das auch gern mit aber wir haben uns
vorgenommen mindestens jeden tag ein
salat zu essen das kann bei mir immer so
ein bisschen zu kurz und das ist jetzt
unser vorsatz fürs neue jahr
vielleicht habt ihr auch vorsätze und
könnt ihr mir einfach mal schreiben und
wie einfach so zum beispiel vom letzten
jahr die vorsätze aus gesehen haben ob
ihr die erfüllt habt oder erinnert ich
finde es sich immer so ein bisschen
schwierig wenn man sich fürs ja
irgendwas vornimmt und es dann doch
nicht machen kann
aber wenn es zur vorsitzenden zum
beispiel salat essen denke ich das
schaffen wir dann schauen
ihr könnt den salat jetzt gerne noch mit
zb chili abschmecken oder mit pfeffer
oder mit anderen gewürzen sowie ihr das
gerne möchte und ich hole mir es noch
kurz mal ins servier geschirr und dann
können wir gleich anrichten so und jetzt
kann ich den salat anrichten
und das ist echt ein salat in köln das
super vorbereiten ihr könnt ihr jetzt
praktisch auch erst morgen essen
morgen ist nämlich dann schön
durchgezogen und schmeckt dann noch
besser
und dazu kann man zum beispiel auch
etwas fleisch servieren oder einfach
wenn ihr ein salatbuffet macht passt es
auch immer ganz gut zum leckerer
mediterraner salat aber ich es denn
jetzt einfach pur und nur so salat als
hauptspeise
und so haben einen super leckeren schön
angerichteten salat der einfach denke
ich auch jedem schmeckt weil das einfach
lecker auch würzig schmeckt und dieses
rezept gibt es natürlich zum nachlesen
auch sally blog.de und ich möchte mich
jetzt an der stelle noch bei allen
bedanken die mich im letzten jahr so
fleißig unterstützt haben
denn nur durch eure unterstützung durch
eure kommentare und durch eure beiträge
konnte ich überhaupt so groß wachsen und
eben zu so einem großen pott kanal auch
werden
ich bedanke mich wirklich ganz herzlich
bei euch allen und ich kann euch
versprechen dass es auch in diesem jahr
wieder sei lecker wird es gibt jede
woche leckere rezepte von mir und ich
freue mich einfach auf unser gemeinsames
jahr und auf unsere gemeinsame
bevorstehende zeit ich wünsche euch
jetzt noch alles gute und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder bis bald